- Most of us call this our "Cookie Zone."
(light holiday music)
- International sweets are interesting.
Some of them are gooey,
and drippy, and flaky.
- I happen to have a particular
fondness for marzipan.
- I personally like fruit.
- So here we have a
jeera biscuit from India.
- It looks almost like a ginger snap.
- Hmm.
- Tastes like there's beans in it.
- Kind of reminds you of
those shortbread cookies
a little bit.
- Doesn't have a whole lot
of sugar, which is good.
- Tastes like corn meal.
- There might be a little baking
soda or something in there.
- It's flaky.
- If you like that crumbly,
crumb sensation in your mouth,
I guess someone might like that.
- Looks like a nice little maple leaf.
- Let's see what it tastes like.
- Tastes like maple.
- Reminds me of little animal crackers
that you might have had
when you were a kid.
Not the frosted ones,
just the plain brown ones.
- Crunchy, crumbly.
It has a dramatic graham
cracker aftertaste.
- Reminds me of when I was a kid
and my mom used to mix up
peanut butter and honey
and put it on bread for us.
- We're going to take
just a little bit of it
off like this.
We're gong to place it
on the tip of my tongue.
Almost a marzipan-y quality to it.
- It's a dandy.
- The old Australian Tim Tam.
- G'day mate.
- G'day mates.
This is Santa from down under.
- Chocolate.
It reminds me of making chocolate cake
with my grandmother.
- Nice crunch.
- The chocolate taste
doesn't just jump out at you.
It lies there in the
mouth saying, "Savor me."
- You know, kind of sensual.
- Superb aftertaste.
- I'm going to have to
go to Australia again.
- A bicho.
- It has a density kind
of feel of a doughnut.
It has a lot more chew
than I was expecting.
- Mmm mmm mmm.
- Big overgrown Twinky.
Maybe it's Twinky's uncle.
- It does have a real
eggy kind of a feel to it.
- You know that you're going to enjoy it
down to the last bite.
- Well they were all delicious.
- This Santa says, Bravo,
and a big two thumbs up.
- You've hit some unusual ones
here today, I'll tell you.
- That's the beauty of the world,
we all have our different cultures
and we all have our different tastes.
- But I love the graham cracker outside.
- Santa said graham crapper. (laughs)